uh we're going to be
also looking at this talk a little bit
more in that experimental design um in
these sort of hybrid models settings
um
our speaker dan russo is a professor at
uh
columbia business school
he got his phd at stanford and did a
short stint that uh assistant professor
at northwestern uh before going to
columbia um
looking forward to his talk
thanks ken
okay
so yeah i'm dan russo what i'll talk
about today is joint work with chao chin
and um
we're going to be thinking about
multi-on-banded experiments
and in particular we'll be thinking
about this kind of fundamental tension
between
um additivity really the
key design principle that one usually
thinks about in bandits and attention uh
where they they risk confounding in
settings where there's non-stationarity
during the time period of the experiment
okay
so
for most of my career i've been
interested in all these problems that
involve
interactive learning
and uh for most people who work in this
area i think uh
the
you know this is kind of a timeless
field but uh
it's spurred on in by this
explosion of interactive data sources in
the world
now a
key paradigm for this is
this class of problems is the multi-arm
bandit problem
i'll show you here a little video from
stitch fix
who employ the thompson sampling
algorithm which we'll be building on
today
um in that
setup there's a bunch of different arms
a through f
the
agent here this octopus-like thing is
beginning with prior beliefs about the
quality of each of the arms
and then it's going to go sequentially
pulling the arms
and trying to figure out which one to
deploy in the future
okay
i really rely on companies to create
better videos than us i like this so and
one thing if you know you really go back
and look at how it plays here
one key feature is that when it figures
out an arm is really bad it discards
that
right once once it learns it's bad which
could take very few samples it doesn't
keep playing that arm really most of the
samples are gathered from the good arms
the basic idea there that adaptivity
could offer greater efficiency that's
kind of the key idea in this field
and
classical theory uh crystallizes this uh
going back to lyon robbins crystallizes
that benefit
in problems with small decision spaces
but as you look toward more complex
problems it's often really crucial that
you
deploy some additivity in your
information
as you
learn in a decision problem about which
actions are good you zero in on the
competitive part of the decision space
and discard the rest
you can kind of convince yourself this
in different ways in the shortest path
problem there's an exponential number of
paths just can't try them all you need
some smarter way to search
if you think about convex optimization
kinds of algorithms we use there
they pretty
quickly zero in on a part of the space
discarding the rest with a few
measurements
so the theory in this field really
emphasizes this aspect of the design
now
there are lots of documented industry
applications of banded algorithms
they're used in different companies the
academic literature has picked this up
and you see specialized models in all
sorts of
disparate areas
things i don't even have up here drug
design
but if you're a person who works on this
field it's worth kind of
being a bit humble and taking a step
back and realizing that despite all the
promise of this
efficient adaptivity
classical randomized control trials are
really still the gold standard in most
areas
we seem to be missing something
and i don't think it's just kind of the
engineering effort to deploy the
algorithms so here is a description from
the lift tech blob blog
it says the outside world often has more
a much larger effect on metrics than
product changes do
users can behave very differently
depending on the day of the week the
time
of the year the weather and whether they
learned about the website through an
online ad or found the site organically
controlled experiments isolate the
impact of
product change while controlling for the
aforementioned factors so that's how
they're thinking about what's important
about running experiments
so
a special case of our model
it's actually an easy special case of
our model in some sense is going to
generate plots and scenarios like what
i've shown on the bottom here
and in problems like this there's a kind
of a core tension
between efficiency through
where what you want to do is use early
measurements to quickly zero in on the
most effective part of the decision
space
if you tilt your head a bit you can see
that this kind of adductivity is really
saying you want there to be a pattern
across time in how you select actions
right
you mostly want to select the action the
bad actions at the beginning and not
much later on
so there's a tension where when there's
a pattern to how you select actions
across time
you can risk confounding
so here if you mostly played
um
arm three
at the beginning and you mostly played
arm one
kind of here in the middle
you may uh mistakingly think that arm3
looks better than normal
just due to when you play
so
what i want to do in this work
is
well there's going to be a modeling
component an algorithm component
and in terms of modeling i want to write
down a model that can generate plots
like that and richer ones
and uh
generally take seriously some of the
concerns underlying classic randomized
control trials take seriously the
motivation of that lifttech block
and
you'll see kind of a new twist on
a model of bandit experiments with many
of the same elements but if you look at
it carefully
doing well in certain hard instances is
going to require robustness to delay
robustness to non-stationary confounding
factors
in terms of algorithms we don't want to
start from scratch instead we're going
to take the thompson sampling algorithm
that stitchfix was using
and see whether we can just carefully
tweak it
so we're going to come up with
a sort of
careful but pretty simple way to tweak
these algorithms to make them
more robust uh to certain model factors
and then finally
where a lot of our time was spent is in
this theory component we're going to
have two sorts of results
one that generates very hard instances
and stress tests
whether we still get
good regret bounds of a certain kind in
those those settings
and one that asks
in the other extreme
if you had a more
benign stationary environment do we get
these kind of like ly robin style
efficiency through additivity
now the nature of
under of a talk like this is that you
kind of need to do the first part to do
the second
and you kind of need the second part to
do the third
so
i will probably run out of time and not
do sufficient depth on the third part
it's an unfortunate factor of studying a
new model
so i'll give you sort of some teasers up
front so if you're someone who's
interested mostly in the third part
there are a few
things that i think are interesting here
one is uh we're going to see some
results about the importance of
randomization so maybe the two most
common design principles for
multi-unbanded problems are thomson
sampling and ucb
and if you asked me many years ago i
would have thought they're mostly
working the same
right they work well in about the same
settings and work poorly in about the
same settings
in our setting though we're going to see
a provable gap
so problems where ucb really really
fails and yet thompson sampling works
pretty robustly and i think that the key
is randomization
a second kind of
interesting nugget is we're gonna use
context
like the uh time of day or something in
the lift example just to deconfound our
inferences
and uh
in those in our results
the price of doing that is going to be
very very small
okay so if you're used to contextual
banded mounds or something they say that
you should be very judicious
uh how rich you make your features
that is not going to happen here
and the the last bit is our
policies are going to be
we call context independent
meaning
in a certain setting we're going to take
actions after seeing the contacts and
there's actually going to turn out to be
no price
so with a intro that's that broad you
kind of can't give
it's hard to give a related work
discussion
sort of uh
whole textbooks uh that are related
worked or something like that
but uh i guess i'll really call out that
i think that the
um
the closest intellectual line of work
it's going to be work on non-stochastic
bandits and non-stochastic uh
best arm identification problems
that lets there be very adversarial
patterns
to
arm rewards across time
and some that try to find like the best
of both worlds
any questions on the broad warm-up
all right
so
to set us up i think it's
worth just looking at one kind of
prototypical example of
an experiment at a tech company
so here
um this is to set us up with kind of
what we want to model so here we have
the um spotify app
and a few years ago they rolled out a
new feature which is this shortcuts page
at the top which helps you return to
whatever is heaviest in your rotation at
that moment
whenever some product change like this
is done
they run an experiment
so what's the goal the goal is to test
out a few variations about what they
productionized do we want four buttons
or six or eight
and should we productionize model
variant a which maybe is trained on a
certain notion of short-term proxy model
variant b which uses a different
architecture but the same short-term
proxy of success model variance c which
maybe uses a different proxy
and
the reward measures are actually these
kind of like more holistic things like
do people use the app more or do they
complete
search do they have to go to search less
often if they uh
so
in the realm of of
models
uh
i can kind of break down the space of
things that people in this literature
study into a
into two dimensions
and the experiment that i just described
really sits on the top right
it sits on the top right in that
well one thing their objective in the
problem is to reach a standardized
decision
they are not going to
productionize one algorithm for me and a
different algorithm for kevin they're
not going to design one algorithm one ui
that i get in the morning and one ui
that i get in the evening
they make one decision and that's what
they launch
the other um
sort of measure here is
they are mostly going to be focused on
reaching a decision
that then gets deployed
and hoping that that works well kind of
going forward in the population
and are a little less concerned
about the reward earned
during the process of running the
experiment
so regarding the first distinction
between standardized decision
personalities
[Music]
yeah yeah i think what's funny here is
that the shortcuts themselves are
personalized
right
the algorithm that they are
productionizing is a personalized
algorithm this is like a meta decision
of which personalized engineering
algorithm that i deploy which deep
neural network do i deploy
[Music]
i think what i'm saying is the action
sets in action
yeah
okay okay so let give me one
two sides
okay because i want to first talk about
the
uh
left to right access here
okay
now i think what's important about
what i'll describe so we're gonna
describe
a model that is also in the top right
corner
intellectually i don't think it's
important that you're in the extreme of
the top right corner but i think it is
important that you have elements of that
so you could be kind of in the middle
but going to the boundary in either
other direction
may change things
so
sort of separate from this paper we have
thought in different cases about how to
interpolate between the extremes
so here's a model that goes between
an objective where you want to stop the
experiment and make a good decision for
the population
and a model where you want to have
high reward while running the experiment
you can kind of come up with
a nice weighting factor where you
balance the two objectives and think
what's the right policy to deploy in
each case
a natural one to deploy
is this thing i'm going to call top 2
thompson sampling
it's an older algorithm i once proposed
it has a tuning parameter in it
and that tuning parameter can be set
based on
how strongly you want to
target one of the two objectives
you could also interpolate the other way
so what i would call complete
standardization to chaba's
comment here is one where you want to
reach a single decision
is invariant to the context
i don't want a different ui for each
time of day
i don't want a different ui to reach for
for each different market
now you could move toward
complete personalization which is where
for anything i could measure about you
i base my decision on that i'm going to
change the ui
based on what you clicked on last
this is what i would think of as
complete personalization and you could
go in between having different uis for
different markets but not
changing it based on what you clicked on
and those sorts of rules i would say
involve restricting the policy class
so what i think is important about this
model is that we're not going to be all
the way to the right
okay a little bit more about what the
dependencies will be then it'll
great so
in some case of with non-stationarity i
only know how to analyze
the photo
if you assume things are id you can get
results that depend on the
richness of the policy class through an
entropy term
roughly through the log number of policy
styles
so sort of uh
if you went to the far left you really
only depend on log of the number of
actions it's quite nice if you went to
the far right
you start to depend
on i'll just say two more sense about
this uh
this is a i think if you're coming from
a contextual abandoned background
suggesting yeah
with respect to best in class then
is best in class
thanks
so i'll just say two more cents on this
before i move on if you're
curious about this there's a whole
discussion in the paper uh of this
tension between standardization
personalization you think if you come
from a contextual bandit background it's
kind of obvious that well what i want to
do is maximize reward in each instance
independently of the rest
what you s what's sort of happening
there though is you're assuming that
your decision
your decisions at different points in
time have nothing to do with each other
often if you really think how these
techniques are deployed it might be that
the user opens the app
and then three minutes later they come
back to the homepage
so there's a natural coupling between
the two if you were to change the ui
every three minutes on them they would
not like it
so that is what i'll call a consistency
benefit to deploying once one version
there's also an operational benefit no
one would want to maintain different
machine learning algorithms like
hundreds of them
you go to the mcdonald's example
there's again a consistency benefit to
having every store be the same as part
of the business offer
and there's an operational benefit too
to running their supply chain that way
the paper has a bunch of different
discussions around these and why they
show up in different examples
i think it's
interesting to think through but
probably not where i want to spend most
of it
so you can just think we're living a
little more to the left
where are we
so
i'm going to write down a model like
this
we are going to take that product
testing example and observe
that
passively
when you run the experiment you don't
just see how the user who got this
treatment response you see a bunch of
other contextual information you see
details of who that user was
you see the time of day when they
came to the app
you see whether there's a promo running
that sits maybe above the shortcuts
and messes with the experiment
experience you see whether they were
interacting via voice commands
and so on
okay
now
the contextual information
is
maybe useful because it's going to help
us control for these
risk of confounding and so on
but it's not something that you need to
run an experiment to learn about
users who are not in the experiment you
still see their contexts
and you can often just look at past data
to figure out
okay how what is the age distribution of
my users
we're going to be assuming that
basically the company really understands
contexts they just don't understand
whether four buttons or six is better
so that leads to the following model
which is a contextual version of the
best arm identification problem
the objective in running the experiment
is to learn which arm to deploy
throughout a population
and you will be deploying that arm
across all future contexts
so with perfect knowledge we would make
a utilitarian choice which maximizes the
average treatment effect
and that's therefore maximizing
the average
weighing across how often contexts uh
are observed in the population
the performance of this arm in this
context which making kind of a canonical
assumption i'm going to assume
it can be expressed through
the inner product of a known feature
vector associated with the context and
an unknown parameter vector associated
with dr
so there's two forms of prior knowledge
represented here
one is uh i'm assuming that this
distribution over context is known
before
the other way we're going to represent
prior knowledge is i'm going to assume
that these
theta parameters are drawn from some
prior distribution
it might be that based on past data
if you're doing a pricing experiment you
understand that certain customer
segments are price sensitive and some
are not
and you'd like to bring that to bear
when you run this new experiment you
don't want to start from stretch
so
there's two more parts of the model
that i'll wrap up here one on the left
is how do we gather information and on
the right is how do we use information
so we're going to gather information
like this we're going to run across
rounds
in each round we're going to see a
context
we're going to pick
a treatment arm to to employ
and then we're going to observe a reward
associated with playing that arm in that
context
now
not not maybe not something you need to
focus on in this talk but
the model in the paper actually also
allows for delay in seeing that reward
but even very long delays
okay
now
how do you use this information that you
gather well at the end of the experiment
we're going to have a history
which summarizes everything that
happened across capital
the price
of
unresolved uncertainty at the end of the
experiment can be
expressed through what stefan
vlogger has called the utilitarian
regret
like that term
it is comparing
the difference
in
utility across the population
if you were to employ the true best arm
in the population
and your
the best you can do
given your imperfect information
who decides what t is because it seems
like in best time identification you the
the platform will decide what t is
so in this uh so we're gonna have two
kinds of results unfortunately
uh
there's some ambiguities both models
like this one model is where t is fixed
and you just try to understand how you
do for fixed t
and another way of studying things
allows you to stop adaptively
for one part of the paper
uh it's much cleaner to have tb fixed
and something that's a real headache is
that asymptotic results
are not
understood in the literature if t is
fixed even if it grows
and so in that case we're going to let
the algorithm adaptively stop
most other parts stay the same
uh i have two questions so uh the first
question is uh so you talk about
confounders at the beginning of the talk
so um is this like is the context
essentially
so
here's what's sort of a subtlety here so
we're going to see how actually many
things like that non-stationary picture
i showed you at the beginning
actually a special case of this if you
give yourself enough flexibility in how
you
represent the context
the context would be an indicator of the
time period
so i'll show you that
and really what's going to be
surprising to me here is whether you
make those contacts iid or let them be
kind of follow any weird pattern is
going to change
the hardness of this problem quite a lot
you have a second question right
so like post experiment you can only
pick one arm but then in the adaptive
you can
change the arm that you pull at every
time right
that's right and how adaptive you can be
is restricted maybe only through this
so
as i said we're gonna
make sort of a small tweak to a
canonical algorithm thompson sample
and uh maybe the interesting thing is
that this this tweet is enough
so
it's really two tweaks um
the one that's really new to this work
is we're gonna
change the learning part
so usual thompson sampling there's kind
of two versions of how you might think
about it one would just act like the
world is iid
and
try to play an arm according to the
posterior probability that it's the best
one
at each uh time step right so it
randomly samples an arm according to the
chance it's the best that version of the
algorithm though would be
clearly at risk for confounding it's
acting like the world is iad ignoring
contexts altogether
there's a second version a usual
contextual banded version that aims for
full personalization it plays an arm
according to the probability that it's
the best one in the given in this given
instant
given what you clicked on next
now because we are after what is the
best arm to deploy in the population
we are going to incorporate all the
information we have including the
context in the past and form beliefs
about the posterior probability that an
arm is the best to deploy in the
population that's what i star is here
and we sample an arm according to that
probability
now there are kind of nice algorithmic
ways to do this especially with
gaussians because linears and gaussians
play really nice
so the subtlety here is really why does
this work
i'll i'll tell you if there's time that
if you do deconfounded ucd it does not
work
i'm mostly going to skip the second
piece here
because it's kind of from an older paper
of mine but that's saying if you wanted
to optimize
not for regretting the experiment but
you want to make sure that with a small
number of measurements you're confident
about what to deploy in the population
you tweak thomson sampling a little bit
so kind of to jackie's question
here's where i think this gets
interesting what i wrote down looks a
lot like a canonical linear contextual
band
so it's surprising that there's
something new here
and that becomes a little more clear
once you start writing down specific
examples
so
here's the example that generates these
plots i showed you at the beginning
in this case i'm going to take the
context vectors to be standard basis
vectors
basically they're an indicator
of what time period you're in
now the ideal choice in this experiment
is going to be the one with the highest
dashed line representing the arm with
the highest time average
across the length of reward across the
length of the experiment
and you could write that as a special
case of our model by taking the w
to be a uniform across
the time periods
now
the
plots below use a particular model for
how the
time specific
performance of each arm varies across
time
it says that there's a fixed arm effect
some arms are just better than others
and then there's a additive and shared
time effect that leads to
maybe just overall higher rewards or
lower rewards at different points
this is actually not such a hard special
case
because you could
sample two arms very close together
and take the difference in their rewards
to form a nearly unbiased estimate of
the
difference in their true qualities
and the tension is what is very close
together in time mean
uh by choosing this kind of a
bandwidth parameter in this gaussian
process
prior
we could generate a case where things
move very slowly so you can compare arms
that were measured far apart from each
other in time you could generate cases
where things move very quickly
and you need to really measure close in
time to have
comparisons across
now the
lyft tech blog mentioned lots of uh
variables in words that they could
measure that are sources of possible
confounding time of day and all sorts of
other stuff features of the users and so
on
so you could take this model and
easily tweak it by adding
a shared observed effect here which
controls for observed confounders
still actually this is not the hard case
the hard case
is going to be when we let things cross
okay we're going to let arms be much
better than others maybe at the
beginning and then worse later on
and that comes in when we add a third
term here it gets a fourth term
which is time and arm specific shocks
and really if you're being bajan here
you can
control how hard you think this problem
might be
by understanding do we put a high prior
covariance on this letting like really
weird things happen or do you put a
small prior covariance on this saying
that pretty much arms that were bad in
the beginning
and much worse than other arms are
unlikely to overtake the others
we're not going to allow
yeah we're not going to allow feedback
cycles where
um
the fact that i've like invested in an
art makes it good or the fact that i've
invested in art makes people bored of it
all right
so
to put words to this
i mean it's always helpful to know what
what's the example that breaks people's
theory
you don't want to say okay what breaks
ucd or something in these examples it's
it's this
this is what really breaks things
and i'll give it kind of a story
the story is that you're running a
week-long experiment
uh trying to figure out how to set a
price for an ipad
so your apple pricing ipads
for that to happen you uh
are trying to run an experiment for one
week long and you want to pick a price
you don't want to have cheap ipads on
saturdays because in the future people
would just only shop on saturdays
nevertheless there are day of week
effects for the people who shop on
particular days might have different
willingnesses to pay
and
therefore
you need to control for day of week when
you run the experiment
now
here the
key feature to this example
is the contexts have the following
setup
the
first one seventh of contexts are monday
so your contacts go monday monday monday
monday monday monday monday and tuesday
tuesday tuesday tuesday tuesday
finally at the end sunday sunday sunday
sunday
and then it's over you never see monday
again it's a one-week experiment
so there's really two challenges here
one that's maybe more intuitive at the
beginning as day of week effects will
confound your inferences if you don't
model them
the second one
is
surprising to me at first is a way in
which non-stationarity
is almost intellectually the same as
delay
here's the issue
if you were to model day of week effects
saying this there could be something
special about sundays
you actually don't see sundays until the
end of the experiment
so somehow it takes the whole experiment
to learn everything that you could learn
no matter how many users show up per day
if you really try to think about it at
just some abstracted level
information delays like this are the
enemy of adaptivity because additivity
is about learning in the beginning and
using it to adjust your treatments
so you can only learn at the end you're
in trouble
so
we are here
uh
in the paper we go through very formally
and show that uh
well first if you just pretend there are
no day of week effects you can get into
a lot of trouble
no matter how many people show up you
might pick the wrong arm to deploy in
the population
more surprising i think is if you take
the deconfounded ucb analog of our
deconfounded ts algorithm
it actually also fails
and it fails because
roughly
through this
carefully what optimistic algorithms
like ucb are trying to do
is uh they are designed based on the
idea that if they
think an arm is really good and they try
it
they'll quickly and they're wrong then
they will quickly resolve their
uncertainty
confidence bounds will go down but if
you think an arm might be really good
throughout the week
but you haven't seen sunday yet
trying it on monday just doesn't resolve
your uncertainty you just have to wait
and so these algorithms what happens in
the counter examples is ucb just plays
the same arm for like all of monday
and just didn't gather the information
on monday that it needed about others
oh
all right
i told you i would run out of time so
the uh
much of the work then
was uh once you go through this uh
modeling and
development of an algorithm and so on is
trying to crystallize
a sense in which
well
the tweak we've made to thompson
sampling is going to allow it to
actually
work robustly in some of these cases
where there is all this non-stationarity
now
in some ways that part is about saying
that if the problem is really hard and
all you could do is run a randomized
control trial
thompson sampling will in some sense
do as well as that
so
the result on the left is a kind of
robustness result
it uh
can really be understood as saying that
for really
hard instances like the day of week
problem
kind of all you could do is wait till
sunday the algorithm does not get
screwed up
and in those settings it's going to do
get roughly the same bound as a
non-adaptive like rct
style
over here we're going to
[Music]
extend
the
machinery around studying the
asymptotics of best arm identification
problems two settings with context where
context give you additional information
and so on
and
there if the contexts are iid
we can really formalize that
this ts
algorithm is essentially
asymptotically optimal up to second
order terms this is like a lie robin
style optimality result
and
uh the trick here is probably not
to get one of these results
um it's
really the hard thing is coming up with
a natural algorithm
that might work well in between the two
cases but gets both
sort of stress testing different things
if you want to do as well as an rct
the easiest thing to do is to run an rct
right and what that uh
would do is not adapt at all
whatever you see in the beginning of the
experiment you don't respond to it and
you're very robust
the way you get the result on the second
is you
adapt as aggressively as you possibly
could as soon as you learn something's
bad you start you uh allocate more
measurement effort away so it's kind of
delicate to
to see whether you can kind of
get both
i think that i will close here and
instead save some time
for questions uh just for the
connoisseurs
sort of say that
if you wanted to like uh learn
new math about bandits this first one is
the robustness result
seems to have new ideas
because it's trying to analyze
uh
pumps and sampling style algorithms
using
inverse propensity weights to analyze
the posterior
all right up close here
um
i was wondering if you could use your
nice example of one day to start with
like
yeah so
here's what the algorithm will do
um
i have beliefs about
the magnitude of all these effects the
arm effect that they affect the
interaction effect right so i have prior
beliefs that allow me to form
a
posterior
based on what i've seen often
and then those beliefs might tell you
that um interaction effects are small
and whatever performed well on monday
and tuesday is likely to perform what
we're going on going forward or it could
tell you that sundays are really
different and
arms below
anyway so as i as i've gotten enough
data i form a posterior about what might
be true
of the future days
and based on those beliefs i ask what's
the chance that arm one is the best
not so far
but throughout the entire week
what's the chance arm two is the best
not so far right across the entire week
arm three and so on
and then i
play on according to those probabilities
usual ts would have
well
different uh
instantiations one just pretends there
are no day effects that's kind of just
wrong here
the other is on tuesday i'm going to
play an arm according to the chance
that's best on tuesdays
but if i really want to set a price for
the week
price across future weeks as this apple
pricing tablets that also is kind of the
wall
so i need to know uh kind of
information about that interaction
effect it was just wondering how
sensitive
like knowing that may also be kind of uh
i think that um so my understanding
is that
if you believe that that interaction
effect
can be completely arbitrary
it can be huge you can change a lot
across days and so on you're really
almost in an adversary
very weird patterns can happen where
arms are
one arm is just clearly the winner
and the other arm just overtakes it
completely even though it was bad on all
of this
really
my
rough way of thinking about this is if
you were pricing many different products
regularly
you would need to look at past data and
try to calibrate basically how weird
[Music]
so
i mean i see like ucb is a badass with
the pair but lynn ucb seems
the right comparative because there you
sort of find the context within
confidence ball but then you want to not
be optimistic for the current context of
population is that the right that
what you're is
is what i'm calling the confounded ucd
it forms beliefs correctly performs
uncertainty estimates correctly
but then plays optimistically
and it
actually doesn't work
so the services variation between usb
and those and sampling we probably need
some actions of what you should be like
the compiled gcp is one particular
example of how they use people could
apply
so is it is that is that separation
or is it
because i could imagine for example that
you classify something like ucp as
having some of it on this boundary
i don't know exactly how to
form the axioms
but i do think they exist a bit it's
really the idea that um
you could be in a situation where on
monday you learn nothing
and if you respond to that by playing
whichever arm you're most optimistic
about in some sense
you're going to be playing one off
because your optimism is not really
changing
you really have to wait till sunday
and so there's something about being
deterministic in the face of uncertainty
that uh
deterministic and kind of like
optimistic like that in the face of
uncertainty that breaks things it's a
good question how to accidentally so it
doesn't look like uh
this particular algorithm
yeah let's leave it there
any questions very much
um